[Musik]
mir fehlen fragt sich einfach nur das
funktioniert ein mensch mit behinderung
irgendwie und der lawinensituation wird
bevormundet aber dass der selbständig
sind
[Musik]
die nachfahren
von dem nicht
nur
blitzgescheit ehrgeizig clever er hat
alles was es für eine politkarriere
braucht aber auch alles was sie
verhindern kann
seine behinderung die kosovarischen
wurzeln ja selbst sein vorname ist ein
handicap
er heißt isla maly und will in den
nationalrat
[Musik]
die geschichte beginnt in zürich
albisrieden monate vor den wahlen wieder
spd kaum ins land viele dauern
ich denke es wird vielleicht würden vom
islam
warum er wird kann und ihre als die
motivation ist und dass man auch
eigentlich sollte das anschreiben
zugesagt dass wir statt in divisionen
die einsatzbetriebe womöglich entfernen
wir unterstützen die islam nicht
wilderen behinderte und migranten und
muslime und so widrig aber eigentlich
schon ganz fest dass mir nicht so in
tente die politik sie haben geschrieben
mal hier aber es ist halt schon als
signal und jedes gerät oder kopf
gegangen und schloss oder und ich hoffe
doch warum hat das so schreiben und
sagen nicht einmal genau nicht und genau
um rund 30 bis jetzt forderungen genau
diese frage stellt sich oder ich finde
es verliere bietet der politische
anspruch oder weimar seit mal kandidiert
will behinderung hat wir unterstützen
die islam nicht nur weil
ein zweites problem wie drüben
buchstaben geschrieben
ich glaube das wird spektakulär die
erste hürde hat er genommen
sie werden ihn der stadtpartei als
kandidaten empfehlen islam ins
bundeshaus eine mission impossible nimmt
fahrt auf
[Musik]
frau mit behinderung diskriminiert als
frau und mann der wegen dringender zu
ersetzen und das habe ich schon hin zu 2
1 2 die situation alle machen mit der
geologie schutz gehören über behinderte
frau barbara müller nimmt nie ein blatt
vor den mund seit 30 jahren erblindet
sie mehr und mehr
seither kämpft sie für ihr recht sein zu
dürfen was sie sein will
wissenschaftlerin müller hier das
trainerin einer eth vortragsreihe
erkämpfte sich den doktortitel gegen
viele widerstände und noch heute fühlt
sich die biologin wegen ihrer
augenkrankheit oft diskriminiert
[Applaus]
kognitiv hochstellen die hoch
qualifizierte arbeit machen dass gott
denn viele menschen geld gestrichen und
ihm so schwer wie ein mensch mit
behinderung stellt man sich räte regel
ein geistig behinderte vor allem
attraktive nischen beispielsweise mit
trisomie 21
aber das genau auf dem niveau der
forschung betrieben auf dem
universitären niveau der schweiz das ok
oder über sie fühlt sich dann einfach
abgewertet
wer barbara müller vorschreiben will was
und wie sie zu arbeiten hat muss sich
warm anziehen wenn sein muss streitet
die thurgauerin mit behörden und
institutionen bis vor bundesgericht
möglich sind wenn es um die geschichte
mit strich 2004 über art von der
beruflichen tätigkeit was ich da auch
für mach ich da auf motive die der
wissenschaft tätig sondern zum
medizinischen masseur
es gibt also das ist die frage sagt
fischer blinder projekt sogenannte und
das ist bei denen immer gut aus über die
manuelle fähigkeit das tanzen aber dass
die akademie findet gegründet das ist
völlig unbekannt und mitarbeiter
da gibt es probleme
5000 seiten akten 17 gerichtsverfahren
die meisten davon gewonnen
fast immer geht es um hilfsmittel die
sie zum arbeiten braucht etwa eine
software die er geschriebene texte
vorspricht oder dann gab es den streit
um einen speziellen blindenstock und zum
schluss luxus verwaltung was ich
selbstverständlich kann anstelle eines
blinden bundes kann ich die günstigere
variante sein verständlicher mit all den
gerichtssaal bisher hat man mindestens
eine viertelmillion frankreich viel geld
verschwendet das muss man sich schon mal
eine pause unbeugsam und konsequent
fordert barbara müller ihr recht ein
nicht mehr und nicht weniger
[Applaus]
[Musik]
god is a dj heißt es bei mir gassi
stimmte sicher er ist dj defekt ex die
muskelkrankheit begann als er sechs war
nun bestimmt sie sein leben aber nicht
diese nacht
[Musik]
am meer liegt mit freund livio auf als
dj kollektiv das herz heute bestimmt an
ihr timing und z
[Musik]
man weiß es besser
das herz war
[Musik]
dj defekt ex ist bereit für die große
chance
[Musik]
amys krankheit verschlimmert sich in
schüren
doch ans aufhören denkt er nicht mal im
traum zu groß seine leidenschaft für
technik und harte beats technologie hat
also in probstried quasi zum festival
auftritte bringen amys körper an seine
grenzen
muss er wegstecken es zählt nur die
performance
ich mache musik damit
[Musik]
herrlich
manager von gefälschten identitäten
zusammen schaffen
[Musik]
ja das sehe hat sein geständnis gekriegt
ich muss mit europa
[Musik]
ich weiß dass ich nicht gedacht dass man
sich an die das geschafft die ski sowie
den schneemassen
[Musik]
für amira sie gibt es nur das hier und
jetzt als dj auflegen bis es nicht mehr
geht
[Musik]
zu hause bei den allianz eine ganz
normale familie in zürich
das könnte sich ändern falls islam in
den nationalrat gewählt würde
[Musik]
islam ali will für die sp in den
nationalrat
trotz schwerer körper und sprech
behinderung oder gerade auch deshalb
[Musik]
heute muss sich islam den genossinnen
und genossen der stadtpartei
präsentieren macht ihm etwas bauchweh
denn seine kandidatur kommt nicht bei
allen gut an
[Musik]
es ist kein abend der entscheidung aber
eine weichenstellung islam alias cat nur
ein tempo vollgas er ist erst zwei jahre
in der partei hatte noch nie ein
politisches amt und will nun auf der
überholspur direkt ins bundeshaus sehr
keck für einen newcomer unter auch
national bekannten politischen
schwergewichten mit einer rede begründet
islam die kandidatur noch einmal und
zwar so wie er es im nationalrat tun
würde
mit hilfe einer verbal assistentin liebe
genossinnen liebe genossen er will ein
bekenntnis kein gratis ticket wer sich
inklusion auf die fahne schreiben wie
die sp müsse auch einen wien nach bern
schicken einige unsere genossinnen und
genossen haben nun das gefühl dass ich
nur in diesem thema bewandert und
deshalb ein ein themen politiker bin
es wäre schön wenn ich von euch die
chance erhielte als erster zürcher
volksvertreter mit behinderung in bern
für eine inklusive politik einzustehen
und besonders würde es mich freuen wenn
ihr mir euer vertrauen schenkt und mich
für talk empfiehlt
[Applaus]
alle bisherigen treten wieder an und
sind gesetzt für eine reelle chance
bräuchte islam unbedingt einen
listenplatz ganz vorne hinteres
mittelfeld mit dieser wahlempfehlung
hätte islam auch daheim bleiben können
[Applaus]
sowieso schwierig
das ist das ist wichtig denn fusion
wissen aber dass wir den titel verstärkt
der islam selbst macht das ist
die enttäuschung steht ihm ins gesicht
geschrieben
er hatte sich sehr viel mehr erhofft
aufgeben kennt islam all ihre nicht nun
will er das feld von ganz hinten
aufrollen
[Musik]
david insee tetraplegiker bekannt als
der gelernte der wieder gehen lernt
möglich machte es eine revolution ihre
therapie mit elektrostimulation
entwickelt an der ep fn wiz
die wiederkehrenden tests bei den
forschenden sind david eine art
wettkampf das ist ziel ich bin ich hab
dich im fernsehen gesehen und ich habe
über dich gelesen und so habe ich mir
gedacht ich will das selber sieht
großartig aus
[Musik]
vom rollstuhl auf die füße das ist kein
medizinisches wunder aber sehr wohl eine
sensation als sie vor drei jahren
öffentlich wurde ging die unglaubliche
story um die welt
[Musik]
ein unfall vor zehn jahren veränderte
auf einen schlag sein leben
ein missglückter dreifach saldo während
des sportstudiums david ist gelähmt das
rückenmark aber nicht komplett
durchtrennt 2016 werden ihm am oberen
rückenmark elektroden implantiert die
elektrische impulse an die muskeln
senden
es funktioniert david gewinnt teile
seine bewegungsfähigkeit zurück die
elektroden erledigen ihren job
den rest muss das gehirn übernehmen nach
fünf monaten reha sind kopf und beine
wieder vernetzt
[Musik]
bislang kannte davids leistungskurve bei
den tests in lausanne nur eine richtung
nach oben
wieder gehen können es ist das ziel und
ein traum aber keine utopie mehr
also ich relativ wieder klagt will was
mir dann in singen kommt ist wirklich
freihändig laufen ohne den rollout
oranienbaum und das braucht man sehr
viel und so steht zwischen hits wie vor
schnitt mit bin ich sehr viel schneller
werden schließlich erwarte aber ein game
changer und freihändige ein wärmen für
die tests im gang labor seine aufgabe
freies gehen mit elektrostimulation
eine aufhängung hält ihn mit maximal 65
kilogramm seinem eigenen körpergewicht
je weniger support von oben desto
schwieriger das gehen
die impuls geben wird von den
forschenden laufend angepasst nicht
entlastet
[Musik]
ok gehen warum da bleiben wir uns der
mut
okay geben wer tiefer 30 25 20
[Musik]
ok tiefer 15 darunter zählen
das ist das minimum
[Musik]
den stars mode raus raus nehmen okay
nein jetzt nur noch überzogen mit sagt
lilo punkt und zwar schritt ich habe
mich so luises internetdienst riches
geschafft und so spezielles nicht und
inspirationslos tourenwagen damit sagt
machen
das ist die situation so frisch und
munter und ruhig benz eine schlechte
nacht
diese oft die muskelkrankheit zerrt ein
armes kräften amir gashi lebt seit ein
paar jahren in der eigenen wohnung das
ist möglich dank betreuern wiesmaier
die beiden sind ein eingespieltes team
optimal nützen
[Musik]
er ist 26
seine statistische lebenserwartung etwa
35 jeden tag stellt er sich der
fortschreitenden krankheit und der
tatsache dass er kein langes leben haben
wird
die krankheit kreyes überladen tod hat
[Musik]
eine eigene wohnung statt ein leben im
heim braucht mut und hilfe fast rund um
die uhr
meyer ist einer von drei betreuern die
den schwierigen alltag mit ihm teilen
weit mehr als nur ein job so bischof
ernannt auf jedes intime job waren auf
einmal
ja da gibt es glaube automatisch nach
anhänger die bindekraft also mit nähe
und distanz
wo auch immer das thema ist pädagogik
der geschäftsführung bei mir definitiv
nicht der fall da ist schon in der hand
zwei verhindern
wir sind selbstverständlich
er hat sich diese freiheit erkämpft
welche kosten die iv übernimmt ist ein
dauerthema
obwohl es teurer käme wenn arminia in
einem heim leben würde
ich bin also positiv
aber das ist wieder mal wurde ich hab
überhaupt wie die finanz im griff
was das plaudern was mit politik und
staat zu machen
das ist ein vorteil für mich wie gehabt
die talkshow die tage verbringt er in
seinem studio wir haben dem soundtüftler
unsere filmaufnahmen mitgebracht er
kombiniert die bilder sofort mit fetten
beats
wenn er jetzt läuft ist das witzig
[Musik]
aus der spontanen spielerei wird ein
projekt dj defekt ex macht sich an die
arbeit
er komponiert und arrangiert die musik
zu diesem film
[Musik]
heinlein in zürich für islam ali ali
geht es heute um alles oder nichts
[Musik]
die parteidelegierten bestimmen ihre
nationalratsliste für eine wahlchance im
herbst benötigt islam wenigstens platz
den letzten im topf empfohlen ist er für
kopfweh und platz 24
um es noch nach vorne zu schaffen
braucht er heute ein kleines wunder
die delegierten bestätigen namen und
plätze in topf ohne gegenanträge das
war's wohl für islam
der rest scheint geführt
[Musik]
abstimmen
[Applaus]
das heißt geprägt
[Musik]
obwohl sie gehen aufs ganze
aber ein neues problem taucht auf mit
rang 18 wird der islam eine frau und den
präsidenten der zürcher stadtpartei
verdrängen
es kommt zu diskussionen und einem
kompromiss
[Musik]
der antragsteller dass der islam von
platz 24 auf platz 20
es ist für euch als bakterien großer
pluspunkt sein er mit sie
migrationshintergrund in österreich
mitbringt und aber auch nichts im
engagement für personen mit
beeinträchtigung des sich die setzt so
viel ich glaube dass ein großer
pluspunkt für euch und ich glaube hat
für die ende november zur abstimmung wer
den antrag der islam muss der platz 20
zur stimme sind aus bezüge mit daten
erheben
vertraglich mit 47 zu 50 stimmen
abgelehnt
das heißt nach wie vor der dfb blieb
also wenn er von der personalkommission
[Applaus]
gegen ghana gewinnen
[Musik]
islam wollte mehr als ein foto doch
seine partei scheint nicht bereit für
einen wie ihn grenzen setzen ihr nur
andere
sie selbst kennt keine klettern in der
steilwand mit einem see rest von ein
paar wenigen prozent
[Musik]
bergsteigen aber müller tut es wie sie
alles im leben angeht
unerschrocken und unglaublich zählen ihm
vertraut sie blind mit bergführer uhr
stajner klettert sie schon viele jahre
ich bewege mich als theologin natürlich
sehr viel im gebirge das training auch
für klima expeditionen und ich kann mit
der hand kann ich hasste das recht das
kann also über als geologe natürlich
dass ich hier bin und dass ich dafür
gestellt dass ich der unternehmen finden
haben wir sehr ich beim gebrauch
also für mich ist das eigentlich als er
eine gesamte art von bewegung will ich
will das nicht sehen kann ich mir mit
der hand brieflich sind wo steiner
markiert die nächste passage grelle
farben und kann barbara noch erkennen
also ich komme langsam vortasten
barbara klettert nicht nur zum spaß
sie braucht das training für ihr
hilfsprojekt in ihrer zweiten heimat
nepal im himalaya gebirge gelangt
hochgiftiges arsen ins grundwasser dass
die lokale bevölkerung krank macht die
einheimischen in den ebenen leiden
überdurchschnittlich oft an tumoren und
krebs das soll endlich ein ende haben
[Musik]
die freie forscherin kennt geologie und
verhältnisse in nepal wie kaum eine
andere
manchmal wochenlang streift sie mit
befreundeten sherpas durch die
hochplateaus des himalajas oft auf über
6000 metern
im gebirge sammelt und analysiert die
biochemikerin gesteinsproben und in den
ebenen versucht sie das verseuchte
wasser zu dekontaminieren
ein einfaches filtersystem auf steinen
und nägeln soll helfen das giftige arsen
zu binden
das geld für ihr nepal projekt
aufzubringen ist ein ewiger kampf aber
kämpfen ist sie sich ja gewohnt
auch in der felswand fightet barbara
müller um jeden meter ihre kräfte
scheine nachzulassen
doch das sieht barbara wie so oft ein
wenig anders
das ist die reinste erholung
das ist relax oder dass ich wirklich
entspannend aber strikt mit
irgendwelchen amt mit meinem büro durch
oder iris wüster schaffte risgard messer
gruppe der oper bringt also ist ein
stück freiheit
genau so gut würde ich doch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
will islam alle reisen nimmt er die spd
mit gea erster klasse und platz
reservation im niederflurwagen
[Musik]
wie so oft kommt es anders
wechsel des rollmaterials unangekündigt
islam muss in den käfig und sich dann
ohne hilfe zur rollstuhl ecke in die
zweite klasse manövrieren
[Musik]
die keine behinderten jungen
wir sind seriös
[Applaus]
[Musik]
islam im bundeshaus als tourist nicht
als politiker islam ali holte bei den
wahlen fast 63.000 stimmen praktisch
ohne wahlkampf trotz schlechtem
listenplatz und obwohl ihn 8000
genossinnen und genossen von der liste
streichen
14.000 stimmen mehr
und er wäre heute als nationalrat der sp
hier
[Musik]
das ganze relativ dynamisch sie zeigen
mit dem stock wo viele worte waren und
sie bestellen können damit die wahrheit
endlich druck machen damit sie dem
schönblick regale und genau geht
spazieren dann auch wieder weg für david
uns zählt nur was geht und was nicht
geht
mit diesem selbstverständnis hat er
seinen neuen job es ist sein erster
schultag als sportlehrer in
festanstellung
für david war schon immer klar dieser
beruf ist auch im rollstuhl möglichst
viele dumme regel wieder speziell mich
und erfolg im beruf erzählt aber auch
für mich ist der zustand
das handicap konnte ihn nicht stoppen
nach seinem unfall kehrte er an die eth
zurück und schloss sein sportstudium ab
als jahrgangsbester als sich david für
eine aus hilfsstelle am kv wetzikon
meldete war der damalige rektor zuerst
perplex denselben sind dort nicht
gefunden
dank das ist absolut machbar dass er
ohne den vorzeige neuen tonhalle statt
und die hotline tel fax
ich bin ganz offen und ehrlich mit ihr
und politisch nicht so korrekt und sagen
das ist nicht nur dankbar
zum glück kann ich sagt lidiya
konventioneller vom tank verlor und funk
probiert es nicht um 10 erhöht
schließlich gehört resonanz gute schüler
lehrbetrieb und das ist einhellig
positiv
die zweite variante eintrete mannschaft
dass wir schnell auf dem fall sind
unseren spieler zwischensprints was man
sie spät
sportlehrer im rollstuhl tetraplegiker
der wieder gehen wird da wittensee ist
keine hürde zu hoch trotz handicap
scheint ihnen alles zu gelingen
wieso ihm den meisten anderen aber nicht
das relative normal slava koop ist zum
unfallort und insofern haben viel erlebt
wo ich glaub's nicht erlaubt wenn ich
vor von dem rollstuhl und für mich aber
ich mag sie dass sie die pubertät dass
ich mit dem roxy bin als kein mitleid
und maxis gab dann behauptete anders und
dann entwickelt vielleicht auch anders
kann ich bin im kopf vorschlag seite der
hitze gewünscht dass vielleicht
schlimmer werden wenn sie die jugend zum
beispiel trug die verantwortung
übergeben
und insofern dass so etwas für mich so
gestehen dass mir ausgesucht worden aber
dann der unterschied vielleicht
vielleicht macht das einen unterschied
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach monaten treffen wir amir ghasemi
der dj tüftelt an den letzten beats für
diesen film
die folgen der krankheit sind schlimmer
geworden freund livio steuert die regler
die armee nicht mehr selbst bedienen
kann
[Musik]
er mag es nicht schön reden dass gruner
jahr hat ihnen zugesetzt
körperlich war schwierig aber was ihn
mehr schmerzt ist das jahr ohne
auftritte als dj
[Musik]
im zweiten jahr von krone hat dort auch
david im see wieder getroffen
selbst die pandemie konnte ihn nicht
bremsen
david bleibt auf der überholspur und
macht beim gehen weiter fortschritte
inzwischen hat sich ein weiterer traum
erfüllt seine partnerin janine und david
sind eltern geworden
jetzt so dass ich ihre extra unmögliche
ziel zu machen und dann komme was wolle
wertvoll innerhalb aber es ist ja gibt
sich meistens selbst mit der studie in
losen zog sie sich mit dem job zog sie
ich habe das nicht direkt usk 18 wurde
die beruf gegangen und ich oft macht und
was die nächste macht mir hat dramatisch
gewicht verloren er möchte essen hat
aber mir beim schlucken
am meisten energie kostet ihn jedoch der
stress mit der ihf wegen der
finanzierung für mehr betreuung die
armee braucht er will das recht auf
selbstbestimmtes leben
mehr nicht
[Musik]
inklusion barbara müller im hoch das
aussehen hoch giftig ist habt ihr ja
schon mehrere male erfahren sie ist
gastdozentin an der uni basel ihre
vorlesungen hält sie legten corona
online ab damit aber nicht genug
ihr gelingt die wiederwahl in den
thurgauer kantonsrat und auch der
dauerstreit mit der iv ist definitiv
vorbei
fast das wichtigste im moment für sie
sie kann endlich wieder nach nepal
einreisen und ihr hilfsprojekt
weiterführen
die inzwischen fast blinde geologin hat
zwar einiges erreicht doch eher kampf
geht weiter bis die inklusion von
menschen mit handicap kein leeres
versprechen mir ist dann müsste ich so
viel für andere erfolg ich mich einfach
weil haben wir das aber und adams in
aber so lange probiert blut mit
behinderung irgendwie eben auslöste und
ihre fähigkeiten der luchs laszlo sehe
schwarz
man sagt dass sieger darauf stehen wo
verlierer liegen bleiben
lisa marie hat sein feuer nach dem
grandiosen scheitern bei den wahlen
nicht verloren
im gegenteil zusammen mit fünf
mitarbeiterinnen notiert er ein neues
projekt das agility center die
anlaufstelle soll helfen projektideen
von menschen mit behinderungen
umzusetzen
rascher und vor allem zahlreiche
in die offensive gehen damit inklusion
in politik und gesellschaft kein
lippenbekenntnis mehr bleibt
isla malerei und sein team wollen neue
tatsachen schaffen
alles andere ist keine option
jahrhundert ist eine hinter uns
[Musik]